going through a rocky separation is
never easy this father says the time
away from his boys is by far the hardest
part there's never enough time with my
kids i basically am there for them and
when they're not there i
try and find stuff to keep myself busy
we've changed his name and won't be
showing his face in order to protect the
children's identities
but james felt it was important to share
his story after he says the court is
keeping him away from his kids because
he's not vaccinated against coven 19. i
think the suggestion that i'm
endangering my children
makes me feel
shocked
the decision made in bc supreme court
leading to a dramatic decrease in
parenting time a draft of the order
shows two hours on thursdays and sundays
james says that's down from four days
and three nights or 63 hours a week the
amount of quality time that i have with
my children is so drastically reduced
it's next to nothing on top of that his
parenting time is limited to outdoors
driving with the children also not
permitted the children cannot spend time
with anyone else indoors unless his
former spouse is shown proof of
vaccination and masks must be worn at
all times it is a
absolutely
concerning decision that impacts
separated unboxed parents
across canada
family lawyer scott taylor is helping
james who is technically representing
himself in court
taylor says while unvaccinated parents
have faced similar orders in ontario the
reduction in parenting time was limited
and cases involved other factors the
children in those other cases
were unvaccinated they were ineligible
for vaccination james says one of his
children has received a first dose of
the vaccine the youngest also old enough
to get the shot
despite his own beliefs he says it's
something he can't oppose i don't feel
i'm putting anybody in danger i'm
respectful of everybody else's choices
i'm not out there causing trouble when
asked if there are any other factors
that led to the reduction in parenting
time like an immuno-compromised family
member or relationship issues james says
no as soon as i get double vaccinated
everything goes back to normal this is
not a suggestion that i'm not a great
parent with many expecting the province
to ease mandates including the vaccine
passport this summer there is concern
precedent setting court orders like this
one will remain it's a mandate on on
every
unvaccinated parent
that they must be vaccinated
or else they're a risk
to their own children james says he's
still undecided whether to appeal or get
vaccinated either way having his
parenting time restored will take months
he says the hardest call right now
how does he explain this to his kids i'm
still there that i care and
that i will continue to love them
the way that i always have and i always
will
john hua global news